this visit comes at a very critical time
in the region we've agreed that the only
solution is to defuse escalations among
all parties and we've also agreed that
dialogue and only dialogue is the only
route to any solution to any crisis
daughter Jabari joins us now from Tehran
and also just take us through what was
said here the appearances are obviously
important but the message here about
de-escalation as well yes this was a
very unexpected visit but the president
Iranian president said that he had
invited the Emir of Qatar to come to the
Iranian capital to hold a private
session on various issues at the top of
their agenda was apparently the security
in the region
and the rise in tensions between Iran
and the United States we also heard that
the Iranian president who said that
there will be a Joint Commission formed
between the two countries to discuss
strengthening of ties political and
economic ties between the two countries
this visit is very very important
because this is the first time the Emir
of Qatar since he became the Emir in
2013 has come to Iran and the Emir
himself said that there Qatar is
grateful for the assistance that they
received following the 2017 blockade and
Iranians came to their aid by opening at
they're having at their disposal the
airspace and the seaports so the
discussions were held in private in a
private session at sad about Palace
where the two leaders met and now we
understand that the meetings finished
and the Qatari Emir has said that he has
invited president rouhani to come to
Qatar at his earliest convenience
clearly this is a message not only to
the regional countries but also to the
international community that Iran and
Qatar are again very close allies and
that relationship is only getting
stronger
what does Katta bring to a meeting like
this the significant isn't it that you
look around the region which countries
can bring any in
Sin Cara is significantly one of them
well clearly it's a smaller country with
bigger means as it were and it has a
vested interest in regional security
especially in the Gulf where the
livelihood of Qatar of course is
dependent on it so there are altruistic
and non altruistic reasons of why Qatar
would want to take an initiative in
order to be a bridge than a hamper if
you will diverse regional security if
you look carefully on two levels level
number one hardly any country in the
region any leader is able to make this
kind of visit while at the same time
maintaining relations with the American
leadership European leadership and the
Iraqi leadership at the same time trying
to bridge ideas and facilitate dialogue
of sort as we've heard in the press
conference on a second level and more
broader regional level I mean look it's
so sad that there is in two countries
two neighbors in the region that don't
have border or other problems this and I
touched on that of course with the
blockade the carriage accelerates there
aren't two countries in the region that
don't have problems and this region is
not lacking in passions it's not lacking
in emotions it's not lacking in violence
what is is lacking is in bridging in
dialogue in trying to arrive at
situation where why violence is not
necessary and pulling back from the
brink of war when it's possible and
Qatar did play the role before the
blockade in mediating between different
parties whether they were Sudanese or
Lebanese or Palestinians and so on so
forth and I think there is a role to be
played here of course for the Iranians
they have their own vested interest as
well to have an important regional
player like Qatar to be coming to the
Hawaiian to be talking about relations
economic business and cultural so forth
it's also good for a Iran that's trying
to look like it was not isolated and
it's really interesting too isn't that
what message Iran might also be sending
to the United States at the same time
because the choice of language I thought
was really interesting where the Emir of
Qatar specifically said the importance
of de-escalation on all sides all sides
so Iran as well what do you take away
from there well the de-escalation and
the maritime security the security of
shipping and the Gulf for the Iranian
and the Qatari leaders to be speaking
about today about about security in the
Gulf and security for shipping is very
important because everyone understood if
a major war breaks out that of course
the first the first battle if you will
between the United States and Iran the
almost measures the confidence-building
measures the fact that we all know and
I'm not suggesting in any which way that
the Emir of Qatar is carrying any
messages and just the fact that that the
Emir of Qatar is in conversation with
the Americans and the Europeans and the
Iraqis and the Iranians means that there
is a dialogue going on and that's
important for the very strategic reason
that the conditions for last week's
escalation remain the same the sanctions
the non-existence more-or-less de facto
of the nuclear deal as the United States
walked away from it doubling down on the
sanctions the as you were saying earlier
that this the destabilization of Iraq
the instability within Iran and all of
that of course are are moving part of
the dialogue the dialogue has changed a
week ago everyone was talking about war
now we're talking de-escalation there
American response to the admission of
responsibility over the downing of the
plane has been interesting they haven't
gone on the attack against Iran this
talk of de-escalation today all sides
are showing that they are very careful
about what they're saying right now
absolutely and I think I mean just to
put it in two words the American
president has proven demonstrated not
proven that he doesn't want war whether
you're on and the Iranian leadership has
proven that did not want war the unites
that's important the problem is not so
much in the predetermined intention to
go to war the problem is that tensions
build up as Kelly
builds up and that has unintended
consequence it's like going to war
because it's so sensitive and we've seen
that from the very very tragic downing
of that civilian Ukrainian flight if
that can happen imagine if it was
something else as well in addition so
the escalation of what could happen
sometimes by mistake just simply because
the tensions are high and that's why
once again I underlined the fact that
it's not just important that we pulled
away and we are pulling away what is
even more important is to have that
dialogue that removes the causes of war
and the escalation towards war in the
future and that was the word
specifically used by the Emir dialogue
yeah Marwan thank you for that mommy
showers joining us there